[Music]
how much of the galaxy have we actually
searched Oh for life see because every
time I'm out in the street someone says
we've looked at we haven't found any are
we alone and I'm trying to find a way to
tell them we're not likely alone but
they know we've been looking for a while
so how do you how do you deal with this
so I try and tell people about all the
different ways you might have to look to
get it right all the different
frequencies be at the right time looking
at the right place all this has to come
together right now that big volume that
you need to search through set that
equal to the volume of the Earth's
oceans all that water so how much have
we sampled in the last 50 years one
12-ounce glass it's not a lot and so if
you were looking for fish in the ocean
are there any fish in the Earth's ocean
here's a glass I'm gonna scoop up a
glass and I'm gonna look at it and there
aren't any fish in there can you claim
that there are no fish in the ocean yeah
I'd be stupid to do so yeah
short-sighted check stupid stupid edgy I
can't say stupid short-sighted you'll be
you'd be an excusably egocentric that's
right and so it's the fact that the it's
hard to comprehend how big the search is
so you can't understand how little we've
done however Exponential's will save us
because our ability to search me greater
technology computing X spatial growth of
storage retrieval of information all
that stuff gets faster and better all
the time
and all the good stuffs at the end right
it's really getting fast ok so next we
might get a garbage pail of water
swimming pool swimming pool of water
there's some minnows yeah we're gonna be
ok and then a lake and then very soon an
ocean
Seth what's your take on that it's
exploration its exploration it's like
sitting around in the bars of Europe you
know 300 400 years ago and saying yeah
what do you think Ralph do you think
there's a continent at the bottom of the
globe right and you can say well what
good is it gonna do to find it if it's
there what we will learn is that we're
unique yes but we're not special I'm
special but if we are actually alone
it would seem to me that our
responsibility is even greater because
if the universe has no other
consciousness in it other than ours it
seems like we owe it to the universe to
keep ourselves going if there is no
intelligent life other than us then the
universe itself loses meaning in a way
because there's nothing to observe it
that was beautiful what I just said well
right now it's time for cosmic queries
these are questions call from the
internet and all about so the search for
life in the universe and anything I
can't have so I'm handed over to this
guy okay so let's do it
David Hamilton my guys where tarika
would it be more likely that any
intelligent signal we detect is simply
an echo of life now long gone how could
we tell the difference and if we
couldn't can we still claim we aren't
alone Jeff yeah well look people ask
that you pick up a signal it took you
know who knows how many years to get
here maybe they're gone well maybe they
are gone but you know what the time it
takes for a signal to get here might be
tens hundreds thousands of years you
know the US Post Office might give me a
letter from my aunt to tomorrow and
maybe my aunt has died since she sent
that letter it's possible but the
lifetime of ants is pretty long compared
to the functioning of postal service so
the chances are she's still around I
think that if we pick up a signal yeah
maybe it's a hundred-year-old signal but
I'd like to think that they haven't
self-destructed in the last century yeah
next James koltes Bentonville Arkansas
if said he discovered extraterrestrial
intelligence how long would it take to
share the discovery to the public and
what is the process involved with making
it public I would say a billionth of a
second
do you tell the press devotion does the
president get to know first no look we
don't have a call list you know start
with this William I mean we have had
false alarms in 1997 we had a false
alarm that for most of the day look like
the real deal and I kept waiting for the
Pentagon to call the White House to call
the only people are called with the New
York Times and the facts are that they
were calling within hours of us finding
the signal yes so this notion that the
government is somehow in control and no
this is not the case the government is
not that high functioning
[Laughter]
you